well in your opinion who is the greatest
quarterback of all time there is no such
thing really yeah so you don't even
think you sit there and say what these
guys are doing today is incredible but
journey knife looks pretty good
you cannot tell me there's no it's
pretty good but you fella Brady's pretty
good but who's the greatest a big video
or no there is no sense news do you do
anything with baseball on that or not at
all right the best centerfielder you're
not gonna say Willie Mays or Griff you
know what I mean
you say best left field you're not gonna
say bonds on the left field first
baseman you're not gonna pick a name for
first base or picture maybe Ryan or rain
are you I'm probably not that good good
a baseball fan and be able to do that
but I would say Willie Mays for sure let
me ask you in a different way you're
putting a football team together I'm
gonna give you positions you pick the
players it's not even the greatest
quarterback who's your quarterback pick
your quarterback well I think you know
that depends I mean there's so many good
ones out there give me one you got it
you got this is your draft pick okay
we're playing traffic yeah first big
quarterback you need a quarterback who
you taking they have to be playing right
now no can be in the past
I'd say paid Manny Wow okay running back
who would you take auto-pay hands down
without question without a question
tight end
what oh well there's a lot of them but I
prep you take John Mackey old cell yeah
unbelievable receiver well I play what a
guy Johnny Morris we caught 93 passes
way back to the one you did separately
right yeah yeah so I think it was pretty
good I mean but I mean there's so many
good receivers I mean I I had a kid I
had woody Garwood speed at Dennis
McKinnon who was just a toughest guy I
would take Dennis McKinnon Ida because I
know what if I threw the ball in his her
he was going to make every effort to
make that catch and if I said you know
what you got to block that safety or
that linebacker you going and blocking
top receivers don't do that anymore they
don't do that's so true because that's
right how about linebacker well there's
so many of them you know I played with
Butkus and I don't know that anybody
played the middle linebacker position
much better but I played against
Nitschke all those years he was
fantastic
singleterry he was kind of a cerebral
combination of those guys I you know I I
don't know I mean I named 3 him there I
could but I'm gone forgetting people now
you know I go back you know I played in
Chuck Bednarik come on you know it's up
for our back I go so and there were a
lot him that could really play the game
and play the position but well committee
because he killed me he beat me up
signature because III think Singletary
ranks with all the with any other
all-time great football player
he seems like a leader you seem like a
guy what are you eight capital he wasn't
even talking to them in he wasn't all in
place class she led by example to not by
words